a woke mob of students is trying to get
their teacher fired it's after she dared
to challenge her school's diversity
curriculum the veteran teacher of 15
years writing in a blistering op-ed
quote yes your children are being
indoctrinated saying that educators are
being manipulated and intimidated by a
divisive woke ideology and adding quote
there is repeated white shaming and a
preoccupation with white people as the
oppressor including staff field trips
with a focus on systemic racism the
students are also angry that she won't
use their preferred pronouns But the
teacher refuses to back down
there is frustration inside the
buildings uh it's pretty miserable on
many cases but yes I believe that the
divisiveness of the Dei message is
prompting
um just a culture of contempt in the
building that is intolerable for many of
us who work there and have worked there
for a long time
okay Jessica I mean how much of this
speaks to the fact that parents really
need to be extra engaged and that you
know what we saw in Virginia in terms of
people insisting parents insisting that
they know the curriculum should be in
place in every state
I think parents should be as involved as
humanly possible whatever extra time you
have you should dedicate that towards
understanding what your kids are
learning play a role in it making sure
that they have as many resources as
possible 100 behind that and I would add
it wasn't just in Virginia
um in the New Jersey Governor's race it
was a huge issue
um that people thought could tip the
balance and that fellow Murphy wouldn't
win re-election
uh you know where I stand on the
pronouns issue that I don't think that
it hurts anybody to use the pronouns
that somebody identifies with but
what a kind of big picture I'm actually
just very happy that these conversations
are happening so publicly now because
this has obviously been bubbling for a
long time right this didn't just happen
in the last two years that everybody
that people had problems with the Dei
curriculum more than it just appeared
out of nowhere or that kids felt this
way and having
the discussion under the sunlight you
know the greatest disinfectant I think
makes it more applicable to everybody's
everyday life and so yeah okay may I
well let me ask the question please but
but isn't it isn't it interesting that
that Jessica says it really doesn't hurt
anybody but isn't the insistence that
you insist on calling them a pronoun uh
infringe upon the other person's
assessment of male and female exactly
where I wanted to go judge Jessica I
haven't sat with you on this at this
table on this topic before so I didn't
know your perspective on on pronouns I'd
love to share with you mine
um I will honor anyone's subjective
choice of what they hope to call
themselves in terms of their name I will
not honor someone's demand that I um
change the English language and what
amounts to objective reality based upon
their threat I will not use someone's
pronouns because it's just simply not
true now the reason I bring that up
though is because though it's notable in
the story to me is the way the students
are protesting and suggesting that they
can get this teacher fired that's what's
notable to me they think they have that
power they may not be wrong but they are
operating based upon intimidation and
fear and I think to that extent the
entire movement we're not just talking
about trans we're talking about Dei in
general is catering to people's
intimidation tactics we have a pandemic
of cowardice in this country stand-up
School District stand up like this
teacher I think stand up and refer to
people by their proper objective
pronouns and if everybody stands up will
stop descending into Insanity can I just
add quickly and I want to make sure
everyone else gets in but on the pronoun
front the reason that I say that I don't
think that it hurts you is that when
people talk about transgender issues
they often say I have nothing against
trans people I hear it all the time
about Leah Thomas I don't care about how
Leah Thomas lives and they would say his
life
when you reduce the conversation to that
to purposely misgendering someone it
takes away from the fact
or the veracity of your argument that
you actually respect the person or you
respect that lifestyle no yeah I don't
think it is Katie go ahead I don't think
this argument is necessarily just about
pronouns um the Dei curriculum that
she's discussing is a distraction from
the fact that the majority of public
school students in this country cannot
read They're not graduating from high
school they can't do math which means
they're not going to have a life where
they can provide for themselves and not
become someone on the street who has to
be put through the system and then get
mental health problems because they're
not able to support themselves because
they had a bad education I applaud her
for saying something about this you know
there are a lot we talk about teachers
all the time and all the woke teachers
there are a lot of non-woke teachers who
have been biting their tongue for years
because they knew that this type of
thing would happen they've been
intimidated into silence and now we're
finally speaking out about it and saying
I just want to teach kids curriculum
that they can use to become functioning
adults in society and then they're
punished for it it also just proves that
in our Public School System The
Authority has transferred from the
adults or the teachers and the
administrators to the children and
children including high school students
need a lot of discipline and they need
it from from adults and they've flipped
those roles and it won't end well you
know Greg the the point that that Katie
makes is so clear only 29 of its school
kids in this school are proficient in
math 38 proficient in reading and
they're worried about him and her yeah
and what's even more interesting is it's
not apparent making the complaint it's a
teacher and the teacher is saying that
the other teachers are calling her a
fascist
well for those protesting students and
teachers my pronouns are F and U
um the pronoun thing is a delusion right
now now here's an analogy you got a
four-year-old boy and he decides after
watching TV that he wants to be a
fireman gets and you get the little hat
for him and he's a fireman and he's
great he's not but he can't be a fireman
but he could pretend to be a fireman and
it's great but nobody's gonna actually
make him put out a fire imagine a
teacher at kindergarten or an activist
he goes no
you're a fireman yep and your parents
they were wrong when they told you who
couldn't be a fireman that is what's
happening with boys and girls right
there is a there's a there's an
incredible imagination there's a desire
for attention that causes this to happen
and right now it's almost
um a social contagion well it is a
social contagion when Marcia Gay Harden
says all three of her kids are now gay
all three of them well okay is it is it
genetic or is it a social contagion and
which is worse because we suddenly
decided you're not born that way now you
can decide but if you decide and it's
all three then you have a social
contagion so what's it gonna be I think
the free speech is about you know
obviously speaking freely but it's also
about rejecting compelled speech that's
my favorite right I love being able to
say no I'm not doing it but let me just
finish on this so why is this variable
so tiny smallest words he she they it's
a power play there's something
inside a miserable miserable person's
life
that needs an exertion of power on
somebody else it's like I have nothing
and when you see a lot of these
activists it's clear they're miserable
they're lonely they're seeking attention
and this is I can compel will Cain to
call me a they power yeah that's all it
is and if you don't do it oh I can ruin
you that I mean it is it is a
combination of contagion and and the in
the power the the power of farce that
people feel all the time just really
quickly on the way out to extend his
analogy it's not an act of disrespect
and I would argue it's an act of love to
stop that child before he runs into a
building and say whoa you're not a
fireman obviously you need
qualifications to be a fireman and you
don't need qualifications to say that
you either were born on a spectrum with
the number of doctors feel about gender
and transgenderism has been uh
qualified to say that aren't qualified
to say that I'm not this sex I'm not are
you denying me especially a mind
genderism I'm denying the I'm denying
legitimate I was born in the wrong body
which has been around
there you know what you're what you're
doing is you're conflating at 20. tell
me what I'm doing and I will tell you
that you don't know what I'm doing I
knew you were going to say that no
don't think so I wasn't even repeating
that well I knew you were going to say
that we spent too much time together hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else